Comedy. F***, man.
Like you started out in stand up.
I still.
Do stand up.
But I didn't know that you opened for
Diana Ross. Yeah, this was.
This was like, Wow. Yeah, I didn't know
that.
Diana Ross, What year were you born?
I mean, I was born in 79.
That's what I was gonna ask.
It was three years later.
You were three? Yeah.
Wow. So we are really going back.
We're really going back.
At that point in your career, I mean.
I was like, you know, just a tadpole.
I mean, I had done, like, One Tonight
Show, and I guess she saw it and liked
it. You know, she needed an opening
act. You have to understand, Vegas in
the 80s is what I call the dead ball
era of Vegas, because it was like after
the Rat Pack, we were too.
We weren't around for that.
I know exactly what the Rat Pack is.
Yeah, I know. But that was the heyday
of, you know, Sinatra and Sammy and
Swinging and Vegas a thing.
Ring a ding ding. Yes.
I mean, okay, you know, broads and
drinking and cigarettes.
Cigarettes. A lot of cigarettes.
Suits with no ties and threats from
mafia people. It was wonderful.
It was great. The Rat Pack were like
they were still there, but they were,
you know, Sinatra couldn't remember the
words he had.
Like he had the tail.
End of it.
The Rat Pack has no tail anymore.
It's very much so.
So at that point, were you pretty much
was Vegas the workspace for you?
No, I was 26.
So you were going in and out.
I had the only place I'd ever worked
before were little comedy clubs and the
places we worked on the road, you know.
So to be in Vegas was like a giant
thing for me. And of course it was
terrible because no one knew who I was.
I was just there to waste 20 minutes.
While the crowd filed in before Diana
Ross was the biggest star in that era
of anybody, I think she was making
something like 400,000 a week at that.
Time, which is astronomical.
And I got two of it.
To.
Two grand.
Two grand, by way, by the way.
Not bad, though. No.
Still great money.
It was so far and above what any salary
had ever gotten. I fully trust me, I
was thrilled to be in Vegas.
I was thrilled to even meet Diana Ross,
let alone open for her.
And I was thrilled to get the money.
But yes, the job itself was terrible.
I wasn't very good.
The crowd was old.
I'm telling you, it wasn't a fun place.
Vegas. Then what?
What was the what was the stand up
comedy breaking point for you?
What was the thing that that acted as
your break?
I mean, there's no single thing because
I think it's an evolution.
Some people it is they do like a
Tonight Show episode and then suddenly
they got a sitcom.
I mean, that happened to people like
Roseanne and maybe Robin Williams.
I don't remember. But yeah, there are
people like that.
Was that your was that your era?
Is that your generation of comedy?
There was Roseanne.
Well, Roseanne, maybe that was she was
also on The Tonight Show in the 80s.
When I was doing that, I started with
guys like Seinfeld and Richard Belzer,
and those were the New York guys.
Okay. Eddie Murphy was at the comic
strip. There was three clubs.
A class already.
Seinfeld, Eddie Murphy Oh, yeah.
You. Belzer I mean, that's already a
Oh, yeah.
Lots of other great ones I'm not
mentioning. And, you know, we've lost a
lot recently. I mean, Richard Belzer,
who was kind of my mentor when I
started, you know, he was she was just
what made.
Him your mentor.
How did he Because he well, he was just
a bad man, you know.
I mean, he was just he'd been a heroin
addict, you know.
He did some shit.
Yeah. And he you know, he dressed all in
black. First of all, he was older.
He was like, ten, 15 years older.
So I was this. I was just 22.
I was just starting and like, he was
just in that little room.
That Catch a Rising Star was the club
that he worked at. And in that little
room.
Isn't it crazy that, like when you talk
stand up comedy, you talk about New
York, you know, throughout the years.
I mean, you're talking about the 80s of
being in Vegas. You're talking about
that time and just embracing what was
the world and culture of stand up
comedy like? All of these things like
have so much history embedded in them
that like, as you're talking about
this, I'm even remembering for me like,
Holy shit, where did you start?
I started in Philadelphia, but New York
is basically my home for standup
comedy. I came up through the New York
Circuit. Well, how long did.
It take you before you felt like you
were good?
I probably started getting good.
2004, 2000, three, 2004.
I was an extremely hacky before then,
but started to put together what was
considered to be a a set.
Right, Right.
And so to your question, it's an
evolution. Absolutely.
You know, it doesn't happen overnight
and it just always growing.
And I mean, I've done 12 HBO specials.
You know, I just did one last year and
I'm going to do another one next year
or whenever. It's still the most fun I
can have.